[Music]
just an absolute thrill to meet you
first of all I'm a huge fan of the show
all of us are this massive fans of the
show and so much to talk about well it's
great to be here yeah well first of all
let's talk about the episode that just
aired the last episode on Sunday melted
people's minds not just me my eyeballs
melted out of my head the reaction was
stunning and I was thinking what is it
about this show Game of Thrones and I
realized you get us to really care about
characters love them think that they're
central to everything and then you kill
them you sick bastard why do you do that
why do you you have this way of
completely surprising people they think
well at least this character I know is
going to be around for a while but no
this is you have a you have a way of
surprising us
I suppose you write the sort of stuff
you'd like to read and as a reader or as
a viewer of television the film I always
like unexpected things and I always like
to suspense to be real you know we've
all seen the movies where the hero is in
in trouble he's surrounded by 20 people
but you know he's gonna get away cuz
he's the hero yeah and you don't really
feel any fear for him I want my readers
and I want my viewers to be afraid when
when my characters are in danger I want
them to be afraid to turn the next page
because it ex character may not survive
it you've achieved that do you now now
that's a television show in a very
popular television show you have actors
this is the biggest thing that's ever
happened to them you must have actors
begging you please please don't kill my
character has that happened yes yes I
will we had recently out here in Los
Angeles we had two premiere for the
third season we had a wonderful party
big premiere at Grauman's Chinese
Theatre and at one point at the at the
party before the premiere I found myself
talking with with three actors some of
whom I was just meeting for the first
time it was a delightful conversation I
had a moment where I realized they were
all dead no they don't know it actually
one of them knew it but the other two
didn't know it yet you know they would
not if they'd read the books
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just like you know the future doing the
show and you know you're talking to a
dead guy - yes but there was one actress
I won't i won't say her name who at that
same party said oh please don't kill me
please don't kill me I don't want to die
I love doing this show yeah and I know
that she does die so I'm very very very
guilty it's one thing to kill these
characters when they're just people on
paper but when you actually meet the
actors who portray them and you know
you're making people are deployed it it
does bring up a certain amount of guilt
feelings okay you know it's curious like
you like you said you have this way of
taking the most central characters to a
show and you have no fear and just
getting rid of them if you were the
writer behind this show the Conan show
who would you get rid of for maximum
thrills and chills well you know that
would depend on who was behind it but I
suppose has the heir to the throne you
would be the conspirator who would be
arming the band with crossbows right
sure me killed pretty quickly by Andy
and the band right
I was applauding that you want to see
that are we sure they have no crossbows
over there trust me
they're in a state where they can't do
anything